[Aplausos]
[Música]
los países bajos son nunca mejor dicho
el tercer país más bajo del mundo y
creedme que de verdad son bajos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
su elevación media es de tan solo 30
metros y alrededor de una cuarta parte
de su territorio está por debajo del
nivel del mar
todo esto es algo que hace que los
países bajos sean también uno de los
países más amenazados por la subida del
nivel del mar que potencialmente puede
provocar el calentamiento global un
momento que no es el primero cuál es el
primero
bueno pues seguro que ya muchos lo
sabéis son las maldivas cuya altitud
media es de apenas 2 metros lo cual
resulta increíble sobre todo si tenemos
en cuenta que a pesar de ser una isla
plana en mitad del océano su capital
male es una de las ciudades más
densamente pobladas de todo el planeta
dicho lo cual eso lo dejaremos para otra
ocasión porque en este vídeo vamos a
centrarnos en los países bajos y en
algunos de los pronósticos más terribles
que los acechan
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es posible que en alguna que otra
ocasión todos hayas visto imágenes como
esta que estáis viendo ahora en pantalla
imágenes recreaciones y mapas en los que
se muestra como la mayor parte del
territorio de los países bajos incluida
la loca capital de ámsterdam
desaparecerá bajo el mar como
consecuencia del derretimiento de los
polos
[Música]
algo que tarde o temprano obligaría
lógicamente a los neerlandeses a emigrar
en masa a países como alemania y es que
veréis según las estimaciones
científicas el nivel del mar podría
crecer en 3 de 30 o 77 centímetros para
el año 2100
los peores escenarios hablan incluso de
2 metros
[Música]
y aunque eso pueda no parecernos mucho
lo cierto es que si lo es no solo porque
esa subida del nivel del mar lograría
inundar muchos terrenos tan bajos como
los que podemos encontrar en los países
bajos sino también por que multiplicaría
el daño de las inundaciones las crecidas
y los desbordamientos de los ríos caso
de tormentas por ejemplo lo que por
supuesto inevitablemente se traduciría
en vidas humanas perdidas cosechas y
ciudades destrozadas terrenos anegados
etcétera etcétera
[Música]
sin embargo un momento porque en este
vídeo os vamos a mostrar como los
habitantes de los países bajos están
trabajando ya para enfrentarse a este
gigantesco reto lidiar con el
crecimiento del nivel del mar algo para
lo que tienen dos opciones ni más ni
menos la primera es luchar contra el
agua construyendo diques más altos
presas más grandes y más resistentes e
infraestructuras de contención más
poderosas
la segunda opción es asumir al nuevo
vecino el agua y tratar de controlarlo y
convivir con él
la población de los actuales países
bajos lleva siglos incluso desde antes
de la edad media sufriendo los efectos
de enormes inundaciones que
periódicamente terminaban con la vida de
decenas y decenas de miles de personas
tan solo la conocida como inundación de
santalucía del año 1200 87 terminó con
la vida de entre 50.000 y 80.000
personas y sabéis que ya en esa época
existían diques de contención una obra
hidráulica avanzada para la época
hablamos de hace más de 700 años
tal y como veis hablamos de un pueblo
muy acostumbrado a convivir luchar
contra el agua a partes iguales pero
amigos de visual política ahora las
grandes preguntas que nos podemos hacer
son cómo diantres se están preparando
los neerlandeses para el futuro
realmente se puede hacer algo podrán los
países bajos sobrevivir al calentamiento
global si finalmente se produce el
derretimiento parcial de los polos y el
consiguiente incremento del nivel del
mar pues atentos
[Música]
un riesgo natural o riesgo humano
vale si nos sorprendemos a nadie es
evidente que las crecidas son un gran
riesgo para los países bajos así como
para una buena parte del mundo sí ya lo
sé si algo nos caracteriza a los seres
humanos es nuestra capacidad
precisamente para adaptarnos
enfrentarnos a las adversidades y
superar prácticamente cualquier riesgo
que la naturaleza nos ha planteado pero
de momento esta amenaza está sobre la
mesa todavía por resolver ahora bien de
qué riesgo estamos exactamente hablando
en este caso es acaso el mar el riesgo o
somos nosotros los humanos
el auténtico riesgo fijaos este es el
mapa de todas las zonas ganadas al mar
desde el siglo 14 en los países bajos
tal y como podéis ver los neerlandeses
han ido comiendo el espacio al mar
durante siglos construyendo ciudades y
cultivos en zonas con alto riesgo de
inundación zonas que antes eran agua y
que algún día podrán volver a serlo
[Música]
al fin y al cabo esto ha sido lo que ha
ocurrido durante millones y millones de
años el mar avanzaba y retrocedido hasta
dibujar el gran mapa que conocemos hoy
que se terminó de configurar hace
aproximadamente 6000 años vamos en
tiempo geológico prácticamente antes de
ayer el problema viene cuando el ritmo
de calentamiento natural se acelera por
la acción humana que es precisamente lo
que parece que está ocurriendo
[Música]
con lo cual amigos para entender la
situación a nivel mundial y en concreto
la de los países bajos podemos decir que
nos enfrentamos a dos grandes retos y lo
cierto es que los dos son
fundamentalmente humanos
el primero de ellos es ralentizar el
calentamiento global hacia niveles lo
más próximos posibles al calentamiento
natural y segundo evitar ocupar espacios
de alto riesgo como paul there's que son
terrenos ganados al mar o llanura de
inundación próximas a ríos que son las
zonas inundables en caso de crecidas
naturales
[Música]
a ver os hago una pregunta si construyó
mi casa en la zona inundable próxima a
un río y un día viene una crecida y se
me inunda la culpa es mía o es del río y
la crecida
a ver tal vez bajo el punto de vista
general muchos culpamos al río pero
amigos en los países bajos tienen una
cultura de convivencia con el agua muy
arraigada por así decirlo tienen muy
interiorizado que ellos son los
invitados es decir que ocupan un lugar
que antes ocupaba el mar y que tienen
que seguir coexistiendo
y aquí está lo que les hace diferentes
especiales pero queréis saber de qué
diantres estamos hablando exactamente
pues fijaos
[Música]
en la batalla contra el mar cambio de
estrategia
amigos de visual politics y algún
aprendiz de los habitantes de estas
tierras con el paso de los años es que
luchar contra el mar es una batalla
perdida un fracaso seguro
[Música]
veréis me explico la estrategia de
protección mediante diques barreras
lunares represas y embalses con el fin
de controlar las subidas del nivel del
mar ha sido utilizada durante siglos y
muy especialmente durante el siglo 20
el mayor exponente de esta estrategia
pública de protección frente al marq fue
el proyecto delta works o plan delta
desarrollado tras la gran inundación de
1953 que acabó con la vida de casi 2.000
personas en una sola noche
el proyecto se completó en el año 1997
con la construcción de más land caring
una gigantesca barrera acerca de
rotterdam con dos compuertas tan grandes
como dos torres eiffel tumbadas tardan
dos horas en cerrarse durante las
últimas dos décadas las compuertas de
esta barrera no han sido aún utilizadas
para contener ninguna inundación masiva
pero amigos los países bajos sacaron
adelante el plan delta con el objetivo
de que fuera una protección efectiva
durante por lo menos 200 años
un momento porque hay algo que estamos
pasando por alto el plan delta es un
proyecto del siglo pasado y lo cierto es
que a lo largo de las últimas décadas el
conocimiento sobre las subidas del nivel
del mar y sus efectos ha crecido un
montón
[Música]
precisamente por eso ahora en los países
bajos han cambiado de perspectiva veréis
tras delta works los holandeses han
pasado del ímpetu por más y más diques
cada vez más altos a las inundaciones
controladas y si habéis escuchado bien
inundaciones controladas
de hecho hace muy poquito en marzo de
2019 han finalizado las últimas obras
del proyecto room for the river un
proyecto enorme con un presupuesto de
unos tres mil millones de dólares
un proyecto que ha buscado ampliar las
llanuras de inundación de los ríos donde
hay más riesgo de desbordamiento vamos
algo así como conducir el agua de las
crecidas hacia zonas controladas suena
sensato no creéis
uno de los mejores ejemplos que podemos
encontrar de este plan es in drugs poder
un poder fundamentalmente agrícola que
se crea de una gran zona acuática de
recreo sin embargo como os podéis
imaginar el ocio no es el principal
objetivo de esta inmensa lámina de agua
y canales sino absorber y contener el
agua durante crecidas y grandes
tormentas se encuentra próximo a
rotterdam y también al punto más bajo de
los países bajos en una de las zonas más
propensas a inundarse de todo el país
esta especie de embalse está pensado
para evitar la propagación del agua
durante los desbordamientos del río rhin
que se prevé que ocurra en una vez cada
diez años
pero no no penséis las cosas terminan
aquí porque aparte de los nuevos
volverse capaces de absorber crecidas la
política del gobierno neerlandés y las
ciudades van mucho más allá
los ingenieros neerlandeses llevan
décadas preparando al país con vistas al
peor escenario que se vaticina para
dentro de mucho tiempo 100 200 o incluso
1000 años eso sí que es previsión
en rotterdam una de las ciudades con
mayor riesgo de inundaciones de todo el
país están creando gran cantidad de
espacios públicos con la función de
evacuar el agua y prevenir así un montón
de daños por ejemplo con la creación de
plazas acuáticas como la de venden
planta una plaza que en caso de crecidas
o tormentas convierte las zonas más
bajas del recinto donde normalmente hay
instalaciones de ocio y deporte en
piscinas gigantescas donde pueden
acumularse hasta 17 millones de litros
de agua todo ese agua que hubiera
generado enormes daños y pérdidas en la
zona de alrededor se va drenando poco a
poco para evitar desbordamientos
y esperad porque aún hay más los garajes
sí sí
incluso los garajes están siendo
diseñados como depósitos de agua en caso
de emergencia la idea fundamental en
rotterdam y otras ciudades vulnerables
que es la de crear la mayor cantidad
posible de depósitos controlados de agua
para poner a salvo las viviendas y las
principales infraestructuras osea
inundarse pero controlada mente y todo
esto reducirá un montón los costes
económicos tras un desastre natural
y lo mejor de todo es que esta visión la
comparten tanto la ciudadanía como los
políticos sí increíble pero cierto
no podemos seguir construyendo diques
más altos porque terminaremos viviendo
detrás de paredes de 10 metros
necesitamos dar a los ríos más lugares
para fluir la protección en nuestro caso
incluye no sólo las grandes puertas y
empresas en el mar sino toda una
filosofía de planificación territorial
gestión de crisis educación infantil
aplicaciones en línea y espacios
públicos y la cosa aún no ha terminado
en lo que puede resultar algo más
controvertido el gobierno está
expropiando terrenos agrícolas a
granjeros para crear zonas inundables
controladas sin preguntar ni buscar
voluntarios te tienes que ir sí o sí la
seguridad por delante de todo o eso al
menos es lo que dicen
[Música]
pero sin embargo muchos de estos
granjeros están viendo esto como una
oportunidad para cambiar para crear algo
nuevo y adaptarse ellos también a un
futuro con más agua en los países bajos
vale sí es verdad con el dinero de la
compensación por la expropiación algunos
ganaderos han optado por retirarse por
jubilarse pero hay otros ejemplos de
reinvención mucho más curiosos como por
ejemplo inventar granjas flotantes si si
lo habéis oído bien granjas flotantes
atentos con el apoyo financiero de la
ciudad de rotterdam la empresa
belladonna ha creado la primera granja
lechera flotante de momento es sólo un
prototipo de 2 millones de euros para 40
vacas que podría producir medio millón
de litros de leche al año si se
abaratasen los costes inventos como este
tal vez permitirían a países bajos
paliar una parte de los problemas que
puede suponer para su economía la
eliminación del terreno agrario en
beneficio del agua ya que son el segundo
exportador mundial de productos
agrícolas tan sólo por detrás de eeuu
con más de 90 mil millones de euros en
exportaciones en 2018
pues con todo esto que os hemos contado
en este vídeo parece que los
neerlandeses no planean rendirse
fácilmente han nacido conviviendo con el
agua y parece que seguirá siendo así
durante generaciones por ello llevan
décadas adaptándose para el peor de los
escenarios previstos una subida del
nivel del mar de hasta 77 centímetros
incluso algo más para 2100
tampoco deberíamos sorprendernos de la
enorme capacidad de adaptación que ha
demostrado el ser humano ante todo tipo
de escenarios el caso es que he visto lo
visto no parece que los países bajos
vayan a desaparecer bajo el agua no al
menos en las próximas décadas no os
parecen los escenarios apocalípticos
sólo se producirán si los neerlandeses
se quedan quietos de brazos cruzados
durante décadas o siglos sin tomar
ninguna medida y hoy aquí en visual
político os hemos contado que eso no
está siendo así evidentemente esto no
quiere decir en absoluto que el
calentamiento global no suponga un reto
un reto que tenemos que abordar y lograr
superar como tantos otros
[Música]
sin embargo lo que os hemos querido
mostrar en este vídeo es como algunas
sociedades han empezado a prepararse ya
para el mundo del mañana y no se han
dejado en cambio llevar por el
sensacionalismo no han optado por buscar
soluciones quizá sea lo mejor pero ahora
como siempre es tu turno vale tendremos
países bajos para rato eso parece claro
pero crees que llegará un punto en el
que ni los más punteros avances permitan
a los neerlandeses vivir en su país y en
el caso de vuestro país cómo piensas que
actuaría el gobierno y la sociedad ante
un reto de esta magnitud espero que os
haya gustado este vídeo y si es así no
olvides darle al botón de like i
suscribirte a visual polític para estar
al tanto de lo que está por venir un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]